Sharon Snyder was a clerk for a circuit court judge in Missouri. And she remembers when she first heard of a man named Robert Nelson. He was in prison, and his brother and sister came in looking for a document that he needed. And this happened all the time-- she had been working there as a clerk for over 30 years.
莎朗·斯奈德曾是密苏里州巡回法院法官的书记员。她记得第一次听说罗伯特·纳尔逊这个名字的情景。当时他在监狱里，他的兄弟姐妹来找他需要的一份文件。这种事经常发生——她在那里当书记员已经超过30年了。
So I talked to them at length, and they kind of told me the story. You know, that he wasn't guilty.
所以我详细地和他们谈了谈，他们跟我讲了他的故事。你知道，就是说他是无辜的。
And everybody who comes to see you tells you they weren't guilty, right?
每个来找你的人都说自己是无辜的，对吧？
[LAUGHS] That's right.
[笑] 没错。
That was not a novel thing at all.
这根本不是什么新鲜事。
No, no.
不，一点也不。
But Sharon believed him in this case for a simple reason-- Robert Wilson was imprisoned for rape, and he had decided to file a motion asking for a DNA test. His trial was so long ago-- he was convicted in 1984-- no DNA test had ever been done.
但在这种情况下，莎朗相信了他，原因很简单——罗伯特·纳尔逊因强奸罪入狱，他决定提交一份要求进行DNA检测的动议。他的审判是很久以前的事了——他于1984年被定罪——当时从未做过DNA检测。
To file one of those, you have to know that it's going to come back, you know, that you're not guilty. Why would anybody file it if they know they're not innocent, because it's just going to come back that they're not innocent?
要提交这类申请，你必须确信结果会证明你是无辜的。如果他们知道自己并不清白，为什么要提交申请呢？因为结果只会证明他们不无辜啊。
Yeah. Yeah, so he won you over right there.
是的。没错，所以他就在那时赢得了你的信任。
He won me over right there, yeah. Yeah.
他就在那时赢得了我的信任，是的。没错。
Robert Nelson didn't have a lawyer. He was writing up his legal paperwork himself from prison, and his motion asking for a DNA test was turned down. Apparently, he didn't do it the right way. Sharon said his sister asked her for advice and she suggested that he resubmit, which he did, and was turned down again.
罗伯特·纳尔逊没有律师。他在监狱里自己撰写法律文书，但他要求进行DNA检测的动议被驳回了。显然，他没有按照正确的方式操作。莎朗说他的姐妹向她征求建议，她建议他重新提交，他也照做了，但再次被驳回。
Now she was just beside herself. She didn't know where to go from there. And I didn't know what to tell her either or offer any suggestions.
那时她简直不知所措。她不知道接下来该怎么办。我也没法告诉她该怎么做，或者提供任何建议。
Then Sharon remembered another case that was being tried where somebody filed a motion for DNA testing and it was granted.
后来莎朗想起还有另一个案件，有人提交了DNA检测动议并获准了。
And I thought, well, I have the file right here in my file cabinet. And I thought, I will just go ahead and maybe if I just give her a copy of that motion, she'd send it to her brother.
我想，好吧，我的档案柜里正好有那份文件。我想，我就直接把那份动议的复印件给她，让她寄给她兄弟。
Oh, I see. You thought that Robert Nelson could just imitate whatever this guy did.
噢，我明白了。你认为罗伯特·纳尔逊只要模仿那个人做的事就行了。
Right. Exactly, exactly. And of course, I'm not an attorney. I have no idea what the difference was that made the judge grant it. Evidently, there was something in there.
对。完全正确，完全正确。当然，我不是律师。我不知道是什么差异让法官批准了那次申请。显然，那里面肯定有什么东西。
This is a public document that anybody could have requested and gotten a copy of. If Robert Nelson or his sister had known enough to research it or ask for it, they could have gotten it themselves. And it worked. The judge granted the motion, the DNA test proved Robert Nelson's innocence, and four years after his first request for a DNA test, he was set free. Justice had been delayed, but a mistake was corrected, an innocent man was out of prison.
这是一份任何人都可以索取并获得副本的公开文件。如果罗伯特·纳尔逊或他的姐妹知道去研究一下或者索要一份，他们本可以自己拿到的。这招奏效了。法官批准了动议，DNA检测证明了罗伯特·纳尔逊的清白。在他第一次申请DNA检测四年后，他重获自由。正义虽迟，但错误得到了纠正，一个无辜的人出狱了。
And then, five days after his release-- it was the end of the work day, 4:30, Sharon says-- the court administrator and Judge David Byrn, who she worked for, called her in.
然后，在他获释五天后——莎朗说是在下班时间，下午4点半——法院行政官和她效力的戴维·伯恩法官把她叫了进去。
--and gave me a letter stating that I was going to be suspended without pay for my involvement and that there would be an investigation. And I was blown away.
——并给了我一封信，声明因为我的参与，我将被停职并停薪，而且将进行调查。我当时整个人都惊呆了。
Blown away, totally caught off guard. Two weeks later, she was fired. She was 70 years old, had worked there for 34 years. She was nine months away from retirement.
惊呆了，完全措手不及。两周后，她被解雇了。她当时70岁，在那里工作了34年。离退休只有9个月了。
She was told she violated Canon 7 of the county code of ethics for court employees, which says that they cannot give legal advice or give their opinions when people ask them questions like, how should I fight this case? Though, as a lawyer named Joe Patrice pointed out in a column on the legal news website Above The Law this week, after Sharon's firing became a news story, quote, "Handing out a public document as a model is not really legal advice, especially when the inmate has already demonstrated what legal action he means to take."
她被告知违反了县政府法院员工道德准则第7条，该准则规定，当人们询问诸如“我该如何打这场官司？”之类的问题时，员工不能提供法律建议或发表意见。尽管正如一位名叫乔·帕特里斯的律师本周在法律新闻网站《法律之上》的专栏中指出的那样，在莎朗被解雇成为新闻后，他写道：“分发一份公开文件作为模板并不是真正的法律建议，尤其是当囚犯已经表明他打算采取什么法律行动时。”
You can see how Sharon could be confused about where to draw the line in this case.
你可以看出莎朗为什么会困惑在这个案件中界限到底在哪里。
I mean, do you think it was even wrong what you did?
我的意思是，你认为你做的事哪怕有一点错吗？
Not really. Not really. I did, maybe, at first. I was willing to chastise myself and say, you've been a very bad girl. But in thinking it over, being it's a fact that it is a public record, she could've obtained that, then I made it just a little easier on her.
并不觉得。真的不觉得。起初也许有过。我曾愿意惩罚自己，对自己说，你真是个坏女孩。但仔细想想，既然那是公开记录，她本可以自己获取，我只是让她稍微方便了一点而已。
So can I ask you-- and I hope you feel you can be honest about this-- do you feel mad?
那我能问你一个问题吗——我希望你能诚实回答——你感到愤怒吗？
Well, no. I feel hurt, which has always been a problem of mine. I never get mad, but I certainly get hurt.
嗯，不。我感到受伤，这一直是我自己的一个问题。我从不愤怒，但我确实会感到受伤。
A spokesman for the Jackson County Circuit Court, where Sharon worked, declined to be interviewed, saying only, quote, "Because of legal and ethical considerations, we cannot comment on a personnel matter." Sharon still gets her pension, but she got a much smaller severance payment than they would have paid her if she hadn't been fired. And I asked her if anything good had come out of this. And I don't know, I suppose I was thinking that maybe she would say she's enjoying her slightly-early retirement, seeing her grandkids more, doing interviews on TV and radio. And I guess her answer shouldn't have surprised me, but it was nice to hear.
莎朗曾供职的杰克逊县巡回法院的一位发言人拒绝接受采访，只说：“由于法律和道德方面的考虑，我们不能对人事问题发表评论。”莎朗仍能领取养老金，但她拿到的遣散费比她没被解雇时要少得多。我问她这件事是否带来了什么好结果。我不知道，我以为她可能会说她很享受这稍微提前的退休生活，能更多地见到孙辈，接受电视和广播采访。我想她的回答本不该让我感到惊讶，但听起来还是很欣慰。
The only positive thing is that Robert Nelson is free, and I'm so happy for him. And I'm glad I did it. I believe that this was a worthy cause. And even though I lost my job and, financially, it put me in a bind, I think it was worth it. So I would do it again.
唯一积极的一点是罗伯特·纳尔逊自由了，我为他感到高兴。我很高兴我做了这件事。我相信这是一项值得的事业。尽管我丢了工作，经济上也陷入了困境，但我认为这是值得的。所以我还会再做一次。
Well, today on our radio program, people who were just trying to help, doing the best they can think of. But as in Sharon's case, it is not always so clear what the best way is to help somebody without unintended consequences, either for the people being helped or the people doing the helping. We have two stories today, including a sheriff who is trying to do right by marijuana growers.
好吧，今天在我们的广播节目中，人们只是试图提供帮助，尽其所能。但正如莎朗的例子一样，什么是帮助他人的最佳方式，而不产生意想不到的后果（无论是对被帮助的人还是施以援手的人），并不总是那么明确。今天我们有两个故事，其中包括一位试图为大麻种植者做正确事情的警长。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《这个美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Money for Nothing and Your Cows for Free.
第一幕，不劳而获，奶牛白拿。
So there are charities that try to help poor people around the world in just about every way that you can possibly imagine. They give computers, they dig wells, they'll build schools, they send teachers or solar lamps. But a few years ago, four young guys-- they were grad students at the time-- decided they were going to try something simpler. They wanted to try just giving money to poor people.
世界上有各种各样的慈善机构，试图以你能想象到的几乎所有方式帮助穷人。他们捐赠电脑、挖掘水井、建造学校、派遣教师或送去太阳能灯。但几年前，四个年轻人——当时他们还是研究生——决定尝试一种更简单的方法。他们想尝试直接给穷人发钱。
After all, they figured, that's their problem-- they don't have money. That's what makes them poor. That's the definition of poor, they don't have money. Why not just give them money? No strings attached, they don't have to pay it back. Let people do whatever they want with it. The idea being, like everybody else, they will know what they need better than anybody else could. Give them money and they can buy what they need.
毕竟，他们认为，这就是他们的问题所在——他们没钱。这就是他们贫穷的原因。这就是贫穷的定义，他们没钱。为什么不直接给他们钱呢？没有附加条件，不需要偿还。让他们随心所欲地使用。理念就是，像其他人一样，他们比任何人都更清楚自己需要什么。给他们钱，他们就能买到自己需要的东西。
Michael Faye, one of the guys who had this idea, decided he was going to test it out himself. During a break from school, he flew to Kenya and tried giving away some of his own money, and it didn't go exactly as planned.
迈克尔·法耶是提出这个想法的人之一，他决定亲自测试一下。在学校放假期间，他飞往肯尼亚，尝试捐赠自己的一些钱，但这并没有完全按计划进行。
Some people said no to the money. And I'll be honest, that first trip, we had one village that said, thanks, but no thanks. We don't believe you. We think you're going to ask for something in return or need me to spend the money in a certain way. And I don't want the money.
有些人拒绝了这些钱。老实说，在第一次旅行中，我们有一个村庄的人说，谢谢，但不用了。我们不相信你。我们认为你会要求我们回报什么，或者需要我以某种特定方式花这些钱。我不要这些钱。
Faye did his best to convince them. Really, he said, I don't need the money back.
法耶尽力说服他们。他说，真的，我不需要你们还钱。
I tried. They were pretty adamant that they didn't want it. They said, I just don't believe it. I think you will come back in six months or a year and ask me for something. And I don't know what that is, but I don't trust you.
我尝试过了。他们非常坚决地表示不想要。他们说，我就是不相信。我想你会在六个月或一年后回来找我索要什么东西。我不知道那是什么，但我就是不信任你。
Which sounds totally reasonable to me. If somebody walked up to me on the street and just said, "I want to give you money," I would be suspicious. But on that trip, Faye did manage to find people who were willing to accept free money, and Faye and his buddies went on to start a charity. It's called GiveDirectly, and it just gives money to poor people.
这听起来完全合理。如果有人在街上走到我面前说，“我想给你钱”，我也会怀疑。但在那次旅行中，法耶确实找到了愿意接受免费资金的人，法耶和他的朋友们后来创办了一家慈善机构。它叫“直接给予”（GiveDirectly），它就是直接给穷人发钱。
Faye and his friends have big plans. They think that, in the future, this could be one of the major ways that we help poor people. Jacob Goldstein and Dave Kestenbaum of Planet Money recently went to Kenya to see how this was working.
法耶和他的朋友们有宏大的计划。他们认为，在未来，这可能成为我们帮助穷人的主要方式之一。来自《货币星球》的雅各布·戈德斯坦和戴夫·凯斯滕鲍姆最近前往肯尼亚，看看这是如何运作的。
There are lots of reasons charities don't usually just hand out cash.
慈善机构通常不直接发放现金有很多原因。
Chris Blattman tells this one story. Blattman is a professor at Columbia who spends a lot of time in the international aid world. He was working with this charity that was trying to help former soldiers, some of them child soldiers, become farmers. They gave them land, they gave them training, they gave them almost everything they could need.
克里斯·布拉特曼讲过这样一个故事。布拉特曼是哥伦比亚大学的一位教授，他在国际援助领域投入了大量时间。他曾与一个试图帮助前士兵（其中一些曾是童子兵）成为农民的慈善机构合作。他们给了他们土地，提供了培训，几乎提供了他们所需的一切。
But they wouldn't give cash. They said that they were very worried about what people are going to do with this money. They thought it was going to be spent on sex workers. They thought it was going to be spent on drugs or alcohol. The last thing they thought it was going to be spent on was agriculture.
但他们就是不给现金。他们说他们非常担心人们会拿这些钱做什么。他们认为这些钱会被花在性工作者身上。他们认为这些钱会被花在毒品或酒精上。他们认为最后被花在农业上的可能性微乎其微。
This, of course, is one of the risks. If you give someone money and tell them they can spend it on whatever they want, they can spend it on whatever they want.
当然，这也是风险之一。如果你给某人钱，并告诉他们可以随意支配，他们就可以随心所欲地花。
Cigarettes, alcohol, weapons--
香烟、酒精、武器——
This is Carol Bellamy. She's a former director of UNICEF.
这是卡罗尔·贝拉米。她是联合国儿童基金会的前任主任。
--just gambling it away. All the kinds of things that you don't want to have happen with money that, just, you find in your pocket.
——只是赌博输掉。所有你不希望发生在你在口袋里发现的钱身上的事情。
Is it fair to say you think most of your colleagues in the charity world would be skeptical of this idea?
说你认为大多数慈善界的同事会对这个想法持怀疑态度，公平吗？
I think they are.
我想他们会的。
It seems to be true. When we got to Kenya, we checked in with people at local charities, people who have grown up in Kenya, who've spent their lives doing aid work, and most of them shook their heads. They had a whole list of reasons why giving money wouldn't work.
这似乎是真的。当我们到达肯尼亚时，我们咨询了当地慈善机构的人，那些在肯尼亚长大、一生致力于援助工作的人，他们大多摇头。他们列出了一长串为什么给钱行不通的理由。
Sam Owoko, with a local group called KMET told us, giving money is a handout. Handouts don't work.
当地组织KMET的萨姆·奥沃科告诉我们，给钱就是施舍。施舍不管用。
What we have learned is that giving people money creates a sense of dependency. People would not go out of their way to improve, to even look for other sources of money. They know they are going to get it, so they sit there and wait and don't care about anything else in the long run.
我们了解到的是，给人们钱会产生一种依赖感。人们不会去努力改进，甚至不会去寻找其他资金来源。他们知道钱会到手，所以就坐在那里等，长远来看，根本不在乎其他任何事情。
People told us if you give money to some people but not to others, you could create real tensions between neighbors or even within families.
人们告诉我们，如果你给一些人钱而不给另一些人，可能会在邻居之间甚至家庭内部造成真正的紧张。
And, inevitably, someone brought up the "give a man a fish" thing.
而且，不可避免地，有人提到了“授人以渔”的道理。
I would rather teach them how to fish than to fish for them.
我宁愿教他们如何捕鱼，也不愿直接替他们捕鱼。
This is Alfred Okeyo Adongo with a group called SANA.
这是阿尔弗雷德·奥凯奥·阿东戈，来自一个叫SANA的组织。
He will be able to eat well for one year, but beyond that, what else?
他能吃得好一年，但那之后呢，还有什么？
Adongo did see something appealing about the idea of giving money, though. You could see him wrestling with it. And he said this thing you rarely hear anyone say. He said, maybe I'm wrong.
不过，阿东戈确实看到了直接给钱这个想法的吸引力。你可以看出他在思想斗争。他说了一句你很少听到别人说的话。他说，也许我是错的。
I'm curious. I would want to see how it is working. And if it proves to work, we would be very, very grateful.
我很好奇。我想看看它是如何运作的。如果证明可行，我们将非常非常感激。
There is one other big reason no one had set up a charity to give money to poor people. Until a few years ago, it was really hard to do.
还有一个重要原因，没人建立过给穷人发钱的慈善机构。直到几年前，这样做真的很难。
Poor people often don't have bank accounts, so if you wanted to give someone money, you'd have to physically hand it to them, which could mean bringing lots of cash into very remote villages. You'd need security so you didn't get robbed. You'd need some sort of ID system to make sure the people lining up are who they say they are. All that would be expensive.
穷人通常没有银行账户，所以如果你想给某人钱，你必须亲手交给他，这意味着要把大量现金带到非常偏远的村庄。你需要安保以防被抢。你需要某种身份识别系统，确保排队的人确实是他们声称的那个人。所有这些都很昂贵。
But today in Kenya, if you want to give away money, you don't need bags of cash. You don't need an armored car. You just need a cell phone, any crappy cell phone.
但今天在肯尼亚，如果你想散钱，你不需要成袋的现金。你不需要运钞车。你只需要一部手机，任何破旧的手机都行。
Kenya has this amazing system where you can send money instantly from one phone to another. It's called M-Pesa. There are M-Pesa stores everywhere in Kenya. They have these bright green signs. The one we went to, "store" isn't really the right word for it. It was in an old van.
肯尼亚有一个很棒的系统，你可以瞬间把钱从一部手机转到另一部。它叫M-Pesa。肯尼亚到处都是M-Pesa商店。他们有这种亮绿色的标志。我们去的那家，“商店”这个词不太准确。它是在一辆旧面包车里。
It's an old VW bus.
那是一辆大众老巴士。
Sure, sure, VW.
当然，当然，大众。
My mom had one of these.
我妈妈曾有一辆这种车。
Ah.
啊。
We used to go camping in it.
我们以前常开它去露营。
Ah.
啊。
It's like a snack shop. It's like we're under a little awning here.
它就像个零食店。就像我们在一个小遮阳篷下面一样。
Except it's a bank.
但它是个银行。
Inside the van/bank is a woman with a ledger book, a cell phone, and a box of cash.
面包车/银行里是一位带着分类账本、手机和一箱现金的女士。
I'd give her 100 Kenyan shillings-- about $1-- and right away I get a text message saying the money is now in my M-Pesa account. And then I'd press a few buttons and send money to the only person in Kenya who I have in my phone, our interpreter, Allan. And it works.
我给了她100肯尼亚先令——大约1美元——立刻我就收到一条短信，说钱现在在我的M-Pesa账户里了。然后我按几个键，把钱转给肯尼亚唯一一个我在手机里存了号码的人，我们的翻译艾伦。这真管用。
Sum received. Kenya shillings 90 from Jacob Goldstein.
已收到款项。肯尼亚先令90，来自雅各布·戈德斯坦。
M-Pesa makes it really easy for GiveDirectly to give away a lot of money. In Kenya, we met Piali Mukhopadhyay, who works for GiveDirectly. With just an old laptop and a spreadsheet with people's names and numbers, she can send money to hundreds of people.
M-Pesa让“直接给予”发钱变得非常容易。在肯尼亚，我们见到了为“直接给予”工作的皮亚莉·穆克霍帕迪亚。只需一台旧笔记本电脑和一个存有人名和号码的电子表格，她就能给成百上千人发钱。
Violet, Adeline, Celine, Benta, Rose, Risper.
维奥莱特、阿德琳、塞琳、本塔、罗斯、里斯珀。
Have you met any of these people?
你见过这些人吗？
I don't know any of these people, but I know them in the sense that I send them money each month. [LAUGHS]
我谁都不认识，但在某种意义上我认识他们，因为我每个月都给他们汇钱。[笑]
This year, GiveDirectly is giving away $5 million. We wanted to meet some of the people who were getting the money. So we got in a car with Piali and we went to find them.
今年，“直接给予”要散发500万美元。我们想见见一些拿到钱的人。所以我们坐上皮亚莉的车，去找他们。
[ENGINE TURNING OVER]
[引擎发动声]
And it turns out, while sending thousands of dollars to people in rural Kenya has recently gotten a lot easier, going to visit them-- still really hard.
结果发现，虽然给肯尼亚农村的人发几千美元最近变得容易多了，但去拜访他们——仍然很难。
[VEHICLE ON BUMPY ROAD]
[崎岖路面上的车辆声]
To get to this one village, you drive on the main road past the sign that says "Equator"-- because that's where the Equator is-- and then you turn off onto these increasingly rough dirt roads. And of course, there aren't any street signs because, really, there aren't any streets. No one has an address. You have to stop and ask for directions. Eventually, you have to get out of the car and walk down a path.
要到达这个村庄，你得开在主路上经过写着“赤道”的标志——因为那就是赤道所在的地方——然后转入这些越来越崎岖的土路。当然，没有任何路牌，因为这里根本没有街道。没人有地址。你必须停下来问路。最后，你得下车沿着小路走。
[DOG BARKING]
[狗叫声]
It's very green. There are trees and birds, little farm plots where people are growing corn. And then, finally, by the side of the path, you find the guy who got the money on his phone.
这里非常绿。有树木和鸟儿，还有人们种植玉米的小农田。最后，在小路边，你找到了那个在手机上收到钱的人。
[NOKIA STARTUP TONE]
[诺基亚开机音]
Nokia.
诺基亚。
This is Bernard Ohmondi. He's 25 years old and he's got two kids. He lives in a small house with mud walls, a dirt floor, and an old couch. There's no sink because there's no plumbing. There's no running water. There's no electricity. The way it all happened, he says, is that one day the village elder came by with some people he'd never met. They explained that they wanted to give him $1,000, which, to him, seemed like a very strange idea.
这是伯纳德·奥蒙迪。他25岁，有两个孩子。他住在一个泥墙、土地面、摆着旧沙发的简陋房子里。没有水槽，因为没有管道。没有自来水。没有电。他说事情的经过是，有一天村里的长者带着一些他从未见过的人来了。他们解释说想给他1000美元，这对他来说似乎是一个非常奇怪的想法。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
I had to be suspicious because in African setup we believe somebody cannot give you such kind of huge money without working for it. Even our own president cannot give you, so I had to be suspicious.
我必须保持警惕，因为在非洲的设定里，我们相信没有人会无缘无故给你这么大笔钱，除非你干活了。甚至我们的总统都不会给你，所以我必须警惕。
But Ohmondi said, fine. I'm a poor man-- you want to give me money, I'm not going to say no. The visitors gave him a cheap cell phone and then, a while later, he got the text message.
但奥蒙迪说，好吧。我是个穷人——你们想给我钱，我才不会拒绝。访客给了他一部廉价手机，过了一会儿，他就收到了那条短信。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
It was sent very early in the morning.
那是很早的一大早发来的。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
(LAUGHING) I was still in my bed. I jumped up.
（大笑）我还在床上。我跳了起来。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
My wife asked me, Bernard, what is it? Then I told her, the guys of GiveDirectly have sent us the money. It's here.
我妻子问我，伯纳德，怎么了？然后我告诉她，“直接给予”的人给我们寄钱了。钱到了。
He still has the message on his phone.
他手机里还留着那条信息。
"Confirmed you have received 41,000." [FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
“确认你已收到41,000。”[外语]
All over the village that morning, people were getting their first payment from GiveDirectly and having that jump-out-of-bed experience.
那天早上，整个村子里的人都在收到“直接给予”的第一笔付款，并经历那种从床上跳起来的体验。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
This is one of Bernard's neighbors, Daniel Otieno Ombock.
这是伯纳德的邻居之一，丹尼尔·奥蒂诺·奥姆博克。
I got the message when I was in bed.
我在床上收到短信的。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
And I told my wife, hey, you also read this message.
我告诉妻子，嘿，你也看看这条短信。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
Immediately she saw it and read, she burst into laughter. She laughed and told me, now, my husband, what do we do?
她一看完就大笑起来。她笑着对我说，现在，我的丈夫，我们做什么呢？
It's worth pointing out just how much money $1,000 is in this village. $1,000 is about what one of these families spends in an entire year, so you could think of it as someone coming up and offering to double your salary. But really, it's a much bigger deal than that. Most of the people in this village have no savings at all, so $1,000 is just this unimaginable sum. Daniel had never had this much money at once, nothing close to it.
值得指出的是，1000美元在这个村庄是一笔多么大的钱。1000美元大约是一个家庭一整年的开销，所以你可以把它看作是有人走过来提议给你的薪水翻倍。但实际上，这比那重要得多。村里大多数人根本没有积蓄，所以1000美元就是这样一笔无法想象的巨款。丹尼尔从未一次性拿到过这么多钱，连接近这个数字都没有。
So what do you do when more money than you've ever had in your life suddenly drops onto your cell phone? If you're Bernard Ohmondi, you buy one of these.
那么，当这辈子拿过最多的钱突然出现在你的手机上时，你会怎么做？如果你是伯纳德·奥蒙迪，你会买这玩意。
[MOTORCYCLE ENGINE]
[摩托车引擎声]
This motorcycle is called Bajaj Boxer.
这辆摩托车叫Bajaj Boxer。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
It consumes low fuel.
它很省油。
The motorcycle cost him about $600, and this is not the kind of motorcycle you ride around so everyone will think you're cool. Around here, where most people live on dirt paths too narrow for cars, motorcycles are basically used as taxis, and Bernard bought his so he could become a taxi driver.
摩托车花了他大约600美元，这不是那种你骑着为了让别人觉得你很酷的摩托车。在这里，大多数人住在土路上，太窄无法通行汽车，摩托车基本上被用作出租车，伯纳德买了它以便能成为一名出租车司机。
It beat his old job. He used to work as a laborer. Often, he would spend all day carrying heavy stones from one place to another. That's when he could find work. A lot of days, there was no work at all. Now that he has his motorcycle, he says, his work is much steadier. His kids used to go hungry and they don't anymore.
这比他以前的工作强。他以前做体力活。经常整天搬运沉重的石头。那是他能找到工作的时候。很多天里，根本没工作。现在有了摩托车，他说，他的工作稳定多了。他的孩子们过去常挨饿，但现在不会了。
People bought all kinds of things with the money. One family bought a little mill to grind corn for people in the village, another started selling soap and cooking oil. Daniel Otieno Ombock, the other guy who jumped out of bed when he got the message, bought something he'd always wanted.
人们用这笔钱买了各种各样的东西。一个家庭买了一台小磨坊给村里人磨玉米，另一个人开始卖肥皂和食用油。丹尼尔·奥蒂诺·奥姆博克，另一个收到短信后跳下床的人，买了件他一直想要的东西。
[FOREIGN LANGUAGE] Mattress high-density beds.
[外语] 高密度床垫。
"Mattress high-density bed," it turns out, is basically just a mattress. He used to sleep on a mat on the ground.
“高密度床垫”，原来基本上就是一个床垫。他过去一直睡在地上的垫子上。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
Now I look like a human being. I'm now human being.
现在我看起来像个人类了。我现在是个人类了。
What were you before?
你以前是什么？
(LAUGHING) [SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
（大笑）[外语交谈]
[LAUGHS] [SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[笑] [外语交谈]
[FOREIGN LANGUAGE] Before, I was an image of a human being, but in real sense, I wasn't a human being.
[外语] 以前，我是一个人的形象，但实际上，我不是一个人。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
The thing that really changed his life, he says, was the new roof. Daniel bought a metal roof to replace his old one, which was made of grass. He showed it to us. And if buying a new roof sounds like something that's nice to have but isn't really going to help Daniel in the long run, you've probably never owned a grass roof. Just about everyone we talked to had replaced their grass roofs with metal ones.
他说真正改变他生活的是新屋顶。丹尼尔买了一个金属屋顶来替换他原来的旧屋顶，那个屋顶是草做的。他给我们看了看。如果买个新屋顶听起来像是件锦上添花、但并不能真正长期帮助丹尼尔的事，那你可能从来没住过草屋顶。我们交谈过的几乎每个人都把他们的草屋顶换成了金属的。
I was, yes, very happy. I was very happy about the money.
是的，我当时非常高兴。我非常高兴有这笔钱。
This is Caroline Odhiambo, who also bought a metal roof, and who explained why everyone was doing it. First of all, grass roofs are terrible roofs. They leak, failing to perform what is arguably the single most important job of any roof. When it rains, everything you own gets wet, it's hard to sleep, you have to keep moving around to find a dry spot.
这是卡罗琳·奥迪安博，她也买了个金属屋顶，并解释了为什么大家都在这么做。首先，草屋顶是糟糕的屋顶。它们会漏水，没法完成任何屋顶本应完成的最重要的任务。下雨时，你拥有的一切都会湿透，很难入睡，你必须不断走动找干燥的地方。
But also, grass roofs need to be constantly maintained. You have to keep replacing the grass and, apparently, you can't just cut any grass from the field. You need a special kind of grass, and often you have to pay for it.
而且，草屋顶需要不断维护。你必须不断更换草，显然，你不能随便从田里割草。你需要一种特殊的草，通常还得付钱买。
The grass is very expensive. Because you have to buy grass every year, even three times a year, and it costs a lot.
草非常贵。因为你每年甚至一年三次都得买草，而且花费不菲。
A metal roof costs more up front-- $200 or $300-- but it can last for more than 10 years, and in the long run, it's way cheaper than a grass roof. So buying that metal roof means that, every year, Caroline and the others won't have to spend money buying new grass. It's like they just boosted their income for the next decade. They'll have more money in their pockets-- money to pay for school fees or food or to buy a cow.
金属屋顶前期成本更高——200或300美元——但它可以维持10年以上，从长远来看，它比草屋顶便宜多了。所以买那个金属屋顶意味着，每年，卡罗琳和其他人就不必花钱买新草了。就像他们在未来十年提高了收入一样。他们口袋里会有更多的钱——用来支付学费、购买食物或买头牛。
And buying a cow, that was also really common.
而买牛也是非常普遍的。
Oh, there. That's your cow.
噢，那里。那是你的牛。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
I named her Apala.
我给她起名叫阿帕拉。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
It's a female cow. A very good one, because it produces milk.
这是一头母牛。非常好的一头，因为它能产奶。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
A lot of milk.
产很多奶。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
Daniel told us his cow cost about $400. He says it produces 2 liters of milk a day. His family drinks 1 liter and sells 1 liter for about $0.50. Caroline also bought a cow, but she says don't think of it as a cow. Think of hers as a bank.
丹尼尔告诉我们他的牛花了大约400美元。他说它一天产2升奶。他家喝1升，卖1升，换大约0.5美元。卡罗琳也买了头牛，但她说别把它想成牛。把它想成银行。
The cows are just like bank. When we put there, it's just as if we have saved it in the cow.
牛就像银行一样。我们把它放在那里，就好像我们把钱存进了牛肚子里。
And why buy a cow instead of putting the money in the bank?
那为什么买牛而不是把钱存进银行？
In the bank? You know, money in the bank, sometimes you can just go and take it, small, small, small, small, until it got finished.
银行？你知道，银行里的钱，有时候你会去取一点、一点、一点，直到取光为止。
A cow, on the other hand, you can't fritter away a few shillings at a time. If you want to get your money out of a cow, you have to take your cow to market and sell it.
另一方面，牛，你不能每次只挥霍几先令。如果你想从牛身上取钱，你必须把它带到市场卖掉。
All these things people spent money on-- cows, roofs, a motorcycle-- they seem like reasonable choices. In fact, they seemed so reasonable, we started to worry that people were just telling us the good news stories. So we asked a different question-- not what did you do with the money, but what did your neighbors do?
所有这些人们花钱买的东西——牛、屋顶、摩托车——看起来都是合理的选择。事实上，它们看起来如此合理，我们开始担心人们只是在告诉我们好消息。所以我们问了一个不同的问题——你不是问你拿钱做了什么，而是你的邻居们做了什么？
And then we started to hear different stories. Bernard told us, sure, I spent the money well, but not everybody did.
然后我们开始听到不同的故事。伯纳德告诉我们，当然，我钱花得好，但并不是每个人都这样。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
There's so many guys who are very careless, and I know as you are going to walk around in some homes, you're going to see guys who misuse their money. You'll get that some of them didn't even put up a house.
有很多家伙非常粗心，我知道当你四处走访一些家庭时，你会看到一些滥用钱的人。你会发现他们甚至连房子都没盖。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
They didn't even buy a motorcycle.
他们甚至没买摩托车。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
Some of them are still staying in their grass thatched houses.
他们有些人还是住在草顶屋里。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
You'll just see there's nothing, there's no change in his life, and they misused the money.
你只会看到什么都没有，他们的生活没有任何改变，他们滥用了这些钱。
What did they do with the money?
他们拿那些钱干什么了？
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
So some of them are drunkards, so they probably used it to buy alcohol. Others just spent the whole amount on food. They just ate and became fat and there's nothing to see, nothing has remained of it.
有些人是酒鬼，所以他们可能拿去买酒了。其他人就把全部钱花在食物上。他们只是吃，吃成了胖子，什么都没留下，什么都看不见。
Bernard didn't name anyone in particular, but another guy in the village, a guy named Julius, said, my neighbor right over here. Look, he still has a thatch roof on his house. He wasted his money. He was so embarrassed, he didn't even want to talk to you.
伯纳德没有特别点出任何人，但村里另一个人，一个叫朱利叶斯的人说，就我邻居那家。你看，他的房子顶上还是草屋顶。他浪费了他的钱。他太尴尬了，甚至不想跟你说话。
He saw your vehicle and he knew that you were around. He decided to run away. They're not here now.
他看到了你的车，知道你在附近。他决定逃跑。他们现在不在这。
So we went to the neighbor's house and, just like Julius said, he wasn't home. There were two little kids there who told us that their parents had gone into town.
所以我们去了邻居家，正如朱利叶斯所说，他不在家。那里有两个小孩子告诉我们，他们的父母进城了。
It seemed like Julius might be right, so we asked GiveDirectly about the neighbor and a woman named Lydia Tala, who works for GiveDirectly and is from the region, managed to reach him on the phone the next day. He told her he wasn't hiding and he wasn't embarrassed.
看来朱利叶斯可能是对的，所以我们问了“直接给予”关于那个邻居的事，一位在“直接给予”工作且来自该地区的叫莉迪亚·塔拉的女士，第二天设法在电话里联系上了他。他告诉她他没躲起来，也没感到尴尬。
He said his first wife had died. He wanted to get remarried, but in this part of Kenya, the groom traditionally has to pay the bride's family. So that's what he spent the money on. He spent it on a dowry so he could get remarried, and that's why he still had a thatched roof.
他说他的第一任妻子去世了。他想再婚，但在肯尼亚这个地区，新郎传统上必须向新娘的家人支付彩礼。所以这就是他把钱花在的地方。他把它花在嫁妆上以便能再婚，这就是他依然住着草屋顶的原因。
There was one problem we did see in the village-- the money sometimes created tensions between people who got it and people who did not. Bernard told us he lost some friends over it. They'd come by and say, hey, I heard you got a bunch of free money. Share the wealth. He told them, sorry, I can't. Daniel told us he started staying late on his farm plot to avoid people.
我们在村里确实看到了一个问题——钱有时在拿到钱的人和没拿到钱的人之间制造了紧张。伯纳德告诉我们，他因此失去了一些朋友。他们会走过来说，嘿，我听说你得到了一大笔免费的钱。分享一下财富吧。他告诉他们，对不起，我不能。丹尼尔告诉我们，他开始待在农田里很晚才回来，以躲避人们。
And if you think it's tough getting free money when your neighbors don't, try being the guy who doesn't get money.
而且如果你认为当你的邻居没有钱时拿到免费钱很难，试着当那个没拿到钱的家伙。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
I was feeling pretty bad.
我感觉很糟。
This is a man named Charles Odhiambo. We ran into him one afternoon while we were walking along a dirt path. He was herding cattle. He said his neighbors got $1,000, he got nothing.
这是一个叫查尔斯·奥迪安博的人。一天下午我们沿着土路散步时遇到了他。他正在放牛。他说他的邻居们拿到了1000美元，他什么都没拿到。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
Those who benefit from the project are laughing at us, saying that us who are-- we are sort of becoming a bother to them.
那些从项目中受益的人在嘲笑我们，说我们成了他们的麻烦。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
It's been bothering me all the time, because I always ask myself, why did myself not benefit from the project?
这一直困扰着我，因为我总是问自己，为什么我自己没从这个项目中受益？
The issue came up again when we were talking to a village elder. We were asking him lots of questions and, as we were leaving, he said, can I ask a question? We said sure. It was a question for Piali from GiveDirectly, who was traveling with us that day, and it was about the people who didn't get the money.
当我们和一位村长交谈时，这个问题又出现了。我们问了他很多问题，离开时他说，我能问个问题吗？我们说当然可以。这是问“直接给予”的皮亚莉的问题，她那天和我们同行，是关于那些没拿到钱的人。
He's saying those who are not enrolled in the program, are there plans that they could be enrolled in the future?
他说那些没参加计划的人，未来有计划让他们参加吗？
So, unfortunately at this time, the enrollment is closed for this area. So we typically come to a village, enroll as many people as we can who are eligible, and then we move on. So we wish we could help everyone here, but we're moving on to other places at this point.
所以，不幸的是目前该地区的注册已经关闭。所以我们通常来到一个村庄，为尽可能多的符合条件的人注册，然后离开。所以我们希望我们能帮助这里的每个人，但目前我们正在前往其他地方。
Here's how GiveDirectly decides who gets money. They pick a poor village and then they go to the village and find everyone with a grass roof, because people with grass roofs tend to be the very poorest. Those people get money.
这是“直接给予”决定谁能拿钱的方式。他们挑选一个贫困村庄，然后进村寻找所有草屋顶的人，因为草屋顶的人往往是最贫穷的。这些人拿钱。
Piali says GiveDirectly is aware that handing money to some people in the village and not others is an issue, that it's creating tensions between the super poor and the slightly less poor. In fact, GiveDirectly is now testing out a new approach where they just pick a poor village and give money to everyone, no matter what kind of roof they have.
皮亚莉说“直接给予”意识到给村里一些人发钱而不给另一些人是一个问题，这在特困户和稍微不那么贫困的人之间制造了紧张。事实上，“直接给予”现在正在测试一种新方法，他们只是挑选一个贫困村庄，给所有人发钱，不管他们是什么样的屋顶。
[COW LOWING]
[牛叫声]
We wanted to compare what GiveDirectly is doing with what other, more traditional charities are doing, so we went to another village nearby. It looked a lot like the GiveDirectly villages, except for one thing-- the cows. The cows we saw in this village were much, much bigger.
我们想把“直接给予”所做的与其他更传统的慈善机构所做的进行比较，所以我们去了附近的另一个村庄。它看起来很像“直接给予”的村庄，除了有一点——牛。在这个村庄我们看到的牛要大得多。
The cows were given to the people in this village by a charity called Heifer International, working with another charity called Send a Cow. And let's just say right off, these were some very impressive cows. They looked strong and healthy. They looked like they could eat the other cows we saw in Kenya. In fact, there was a minute where I thought one of them was going to eat me.
这些牛是慈善机构Heifer International和Send a Cow合作捐赠给这个村庄的人们的。直接说吧，这些是一些非常令人印象深刻的牛。它们看起来强壮健康。看起来它们能吃掉我们在肯尼亚看到的其他牛。事实上，有一瞬间我以为其中一头要吃掉我。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
[CORRAL RATTLING]
[畜栏响声]
[COW LOWING]
[牛叫声]
Maybe it's not a good idea.
也许这不是个好主意。
Yeah, maybe it's not a good idea. We should just step out of the corral and ask her to tell us. Why don't we step back?
是的，也许不是个好主意。我们应该走出畜栏，让她告诉我们。我们为什么不退后呢？
The people got these cows told us not only did they get an impressive cow, they also got a lot of really useful training. They were taught how to make sure the cow is getting the right nutrition. They were taught how to keep detailed logs to track milk production. They got visits from someone from Heifer to make sure everything was going well. And people told us all that made a huge difference.
得到这些牛的人告诉我们，他们不仅得到了一头令人印象深刻的牛，还得到了许多真正有用的培训。他们被教导如何确保牛获得正确的营养。他们被教导如何保持详细的记录以追踪产奶量。他们得到了Heifer工作人员的来访，以确保一切顺利。人们告诉我们，所有这些都产生了巨大的差异。
One woman, Grace Ochang, told us her cow produces an enormous amount of milk.
一位叫格蕾丝·奥昌的妇女告诉我们，她的牛产奶量非常巨大。
Mine is 14, 15 liters per day.
我的一天14到15升。
It used to be--?
以前是——？
One. The local cows.
一升。当地的牛。
1 liter, compared to 14 or 15? So it's 14 or 15 times better?
1升，对比14或15升？所以它好了14或15倍？
[LAUGHS] Yes.
[笑] 是的。
This cow makes her a lot of money. She sells most of the milk, and there's this other nice thing about cows-- they have babies, and a calf you can sell for hundreds of dollars.
这头牛让她赚了很多钱。她卖掉大部分奶，牛还有另一个好处——它们生宝宝，你可以以数百美元卖掉一头小牛。
As part of the Heifer Send a Cow program, Grace is supposed to give away the first female calf to another family. That family will also get training and then pass on their firstborn calf to another family, and so on.
作为Heifer Send a Cow计划的一部分，格蕾丝必须把第一头母牛犊捐给另一个家庭。那个家庭也将获得培训，然后把他们第一头出生的小母牛传给下一个家庭，以此类推。
Which is a nice idea. If you're a donor, you give one cow and you imagine it turning into lots of cows, helping lots of people. And all that training-- you could argue this is one of the most valuable things the developed world has to share. All that knowledge about how to get the most milk out of a cow and keep it healthy. If you just give people money, you're not passing on that knowledge.
这是一个很好的主意。如果你是捐赠者，你捐出一头牛，想象它变成许多头牛，帮助许多人。所有的那些培训——你可以认为这是发达国家必须分享的最有价值的东西之一。关于如何从牛身上获得最大奶量并保持健康的知识。如果你只是给人们钱，你并没有传递那种知识。
So if you want to help poor people in Western Kenya, what's better? Should you give them training and a giant, impressive, somewhat-frightening cow, or should you just give them the money instead?
所以如果你想帮助肯尼亚西部的穷人，什么更好？你应该给他们培训和一头巨大、令人印象深刻、有点吓人的牛，还是应该直接给他们钱？
The guys who started GiveDirectly think that question can be answered. They're great believers in data. In fact, Michael Faye, one of the founders, told us that's part of the reason they started GiveDirectly.
创办“直接给予”的人认为那个问题可以回答。他们是数据的伟大信仰者。事实上，创始人之一迈克尔·法耶告诉我们，这也是他们创办“直接给予”的部分原因。
We literally just wanted to give away our own money. We don't have a very exotic story of founding the organization. We were in graduate school, we were studying development economics, we had a little bit extra money to give, and we wanted to know the best place to give it. Surprisingly, we had no idea.
我们字面上只是想散掉我们自己的钱。我们没有创办该组织的什么异国情调的故事。我们是研究生，我们研究发展经济学，我们有一点点多余的钱要捐，我们想知道捐出的最佳地点。令人惊讶的是，我们根本不知道。
Faye and his friends were in grad school and they wanted to give away a little money to help people in the developing world. And despite the fact that they were all studying the economics of the developing world, Michael Faye says they could not figure out which charity to give money to.
法耶和他的朋友们在读研，想捐点钱帮助发展中国家的人。尽管他们都在研究发展中国家的经济学，但迈克尔·法耶说他们无法弄清楚该把钱捐给哪个慈善机构。
There are two questions that we wanted to answer about charities that we found hard. One is, where does my dollar go exactly? If I want to trace it, where does it go? And two is, what's the evidence of impact? Not the anecdote, not the story, but real, scientific evidence that would convince a bunch of geeks at Harvard.
关于慈善机构我们想回答两个问题，但发现很难。第一，我的钱到底去了哪里？如果我想追踪它，它去哪了？第二，影响的证据是什么？不是轶事，不是故事，而是能说服哈佛那一群极客的真正的科学证据。
As geeks, there was one thing that did stand out to them, one place where there was lots of data-- giving money. In the past decade or so, dozens of governments have started giving money directly to millions of their poorest citizens, and the results are pretty remarkable.
作为极客，有一件事确实让他们脱颖而出，有一个地方有大量数据——发钱。在过去十年左右，几十个政府开始直接向数百万最贫穷的公民发放资金，结果相当惊人。
In Mexico, families' incomes went up for years after they got the money. In Malawi, HIV rates dropped. In South Africa, one study found children ate better and actually grew taller. Giving money made kids taller. Faye and his grad student friends read the evidence on giving money and thought, wow.
在墨西哥，家庭收入在拿到钱后增长了多年。在马拉维，艾滋病感染率下降了。在南非，一项研究发现孩子们吃得更好，而且确实长高了。发钱让孩子们长高了。法耶和他的研究生朋友们阅读了关于发钱的证据，心想，哇。
This is incredible. Cash is one of the most researched interventions in development, and there's no one doing it.
这令人难以置信。现金是发展援助中最受研究的干预措施之一，而且没人正在做。
There's no charity doing it.
没有慈善机构在做这个。
There's no charity doing this exclusively. And then you started to get this idea that, wow, this could be something quite big.
没有慈善机构专门做这个。然后你就开始有这种想法，哇，这可能是件相当大的事。
Michael Faye says the whole idea just made sense to him. Poor people know what they need, so give them money and let them decide how to spend it.
迈克尔·法耶说整个想法对他来说就是合理。穷人知道他们需要什么，所以给他们钱，让他们决定怎么花。
Now, in a lot of the programs with those impressive results, people did not just get money with no strings attached. Parents had to do things like take their kids to school or get them vaccinated, and the money usually kept coming for as long as families qualified. But the GiveDirectly guys thought, let's keep our charity as simple as possible. Just give cash to poor families for about a year, no strings attached.
现在，在许多取得惊人成果的项目中，人们拿到的钱并非没有附加条件。父母必须做一些事情，比如带孩子去上学或接种疫苗，只要家庭符合资格，钱通常就会持续发放。但“直接给予”团队认为，让我们的慈善尽可能简单。只给贫困家庭发一年的现金，不附加任何条件。
To figure out whether giving money with no strings attached is working, GiveDirectly is doing something that's very rare in the charity world-- they're doing an actual experiment. The fancy term for it is a "randomized controlled trial." Basically, you take a bunch of people who are all similar-- in this case, they're all really poor, they all live in thatch roof huts in villages in Western Kenya-- and you randomly put them into one of two groups. Group one gets money, group two doesn't.
为了弄清楚无条件发钱是否有效，“直接给予”正在做慈善界非常罕见的事——他们在进行真正的实验。花哨的术语是“随机对照试验”。基本上，你挑选一群相似的人——在这种情况下，他们都很穷，都住在肯尼亚西部村庄的草屋顶茅屋里——然后把他们随机分成两组。第一组拿钱，第二组不拿。
Then you follow everybody and you see what happens. You compare the two groups so you can tell what difference getting money makes.
然后你追踪每个人，看看发生了什么。你比较两组，这样你就能看出拿钱产生了什么差异。
The experiment is being done by independent researchers who go out to the villages. And they do this incredibly detailed survey with people. It takes about six hours per family. Michael Faye says there are hundreds of questions.
这个实验是由独立研究人员完成的，他们前往村庄。他们对人们进行极其详细的调查。每个家庭大约需要六个小时。迈克尔·法耶说有几百个问题。
Have health outcomes improved? Has your income improved? Have you been able to feed yourself and have basic nutrition? How have family dynamics evolved? Do you feel like you have more respect in the family? School attendance, all these sorts of things. You do those in both cases and you compare.
健康结果改善了吗？你的收入改善了吗？你能养活自己并获得基本的营养吗？家庭动态如何演变？你觉得你在家里得到了更多尊重吗？入学率，所有这些事情。你在这两种情况下都做这些，然后进行比较。
They also measure kids' height and weight to see how they're doing. The results from the study are due out later this year and will be made public.
他们也测量孩子们的身高体重，看他们做得如何。这项研究的结果预计今年晚些时候公布，并将公开。
This study is not just about figuring out how well giving money works. It's also a challenge to other charities. Michael Faye's co-founder, Paul Niehaus, was pretty blunt about it. Providing training, flying in experts, paying staff-- all that costs money. If you think what you're doing is better than just giving that money to people, prove it.
这项研究不仅是为了弄清楚发钱有多有效。它也是对其他慈善机构的挑战。迈克尔·法耶的联合创始人保罗·尼豪斯对此非常直率。提供培训、请专家飞过来、支付员工工资——所有这些都要花钱。如果你认为你在做的事情比直接把钱给人们更好，证明这一点。
We would like to see organizations make the case that they think they can do more good for the poor with a dollar than the poor could do for themselves. That would be fantastic. And I think some may be able to make a convincing case. But if you go to the websites today, I don't think you're going to see that argument being made. Nobody even bothers.
我们希望看到各组织提出理由，说明为什么他们认为他们花一美元为穷人做的好事比穷人自己能做的更多。那将是太棒了。而且我想有些人也许能做出令人信服的案例。但如果你今天去他们的网站，我不认为你会看到那种论点被提出。没人甚至费心去做。
So for example, if you're trying to figure out which is better, giving cows or cash, you could do an experiment. Take one village, give the people cows and training, and the next village over, take the money you would have spent on cows and training and just give it to the people. Paul, not surprisingly, loves this idea.
所以，举个例子，如果你试图弄清楚哪个更好，给牛还是给现金，你可以做一个实验。挑选一个村庄，给人们牛和培训，而隔壁的村庄，拿着你原本花在牛和培训上的钱直接给人们。保罗，毫不意外，喜欢这个主意。
It'd be great, wouldn't it? It would be fantastic. That's exactly what the sector needs.
这会很棒，不是吗？那将是太棒了。这正是该行业所需要的。
We called up Heifer International to see what they thought of the idea. We talked to Elizabeth Bintliff, vice president of Heifer's Africa programs.
我们致电Heifer International，看看他们对这个主意的看法。我们与Heifer非洲项目副总裁伊丽莎白·宾特利夫进行了交谈。
How would you feel about a head-to-head trial where one village gets cash, the other village gets the same amount of money spent on cows and training, and we see which does better?
你对这种一对一的试验感觉如何？一个村庄拿现金，另一个村庄拿到同样数量花在牛和培训上的钱，然后我们看看哪个做得更好？
[LAUGHS] Well, let me say this-- I mean, as an African woman, that sounds to me like a terrible idea.
[笑] 好吧，让我这么说——我的意思是，作为一名非洲女性，这对我来说听起来像个可怕的念头。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I mean, it sounds like an experiment, and we're not about experiments. These are lives of real people and we have to do what we believe is correct. We can't make experiments with people's lives. They're just-- they're people. It's too important.
我的意思是，这听起来像个实验，而我们不是为了实验而存在的。这些是真实人们的生活，我们必须做我们认为正确的事。我们不能用人们的生活做实验。他们只是——他们是人。这太重要了。
I think the GiveDirectly response to that would be, we have to do experiments, because that's how we can figure out the very best way to help people.
我想“直接给予”对此的回应是，我们必须进行实验，因为那是我们能找出帮助人们的最佳方式的方法。
It's just not that linear. It's not an equation. It's an ecosystem-- that's the only way I can describe it.
它只是没那么线性。它不是个等式。它是一个生态系统——这是我能描述它的唯一方式。
Is part of what you're saying that you feel like there's a limit to data?
你说的部分原因是你觉得数据有限度吗？
Well, data has its value but it cannot capture everything. There is a limit to it.
嗯，数据有其价值，但它不能捕捉一切。它是有极限的。
If you're someone who got into the aid world to help people, the idea of dividing them off into two groups and tossing a coin to see who gets this and who gets that could just feel cold, especially if you've done this work for years and you've seen that you're helping people.
如果你是一个为了帮助人们而进入援助世界的人，把他们分成两组，扔硬币看看谁拿这个谁拿那个的想法可能感觉冷漠，特别是如果你做这项工作多年，看到你在帮助人们。
I was in Zambia in September of last year, and, I was with a woman whose name is Flora, who I will forever remember. And she had received a couple of draft animals from Heifer. And within two years-- and she had really good records-- within two years, she had more than tripled what she was getting out of that farm.
去年九月我在赞比亚，我和一位名叫弗洛拉的女士在一起，我将永远记得她。她收到过Heifer提供的几头役用动物。在两年内——她有非常好的记录——在两年内，她从那个农场获得的收益增加到原来的三倍多。
And for her, it wasn't just about the money. I talked to her about what the real value is and she said, I am a proud woman and I can stand up and I can talk and people listen to me and I have a voice. And you can't measure that stuff. Sorry, I'm getting emotional. You just can't measure that stuff.
对她来说，这不仅仅是关于钱。我和她谈过真正的价值是什么，她说，我是一个骄傲的女人，我可以站起来，我可以说话，人们倾听我，我有声音。你无法衡量那些东西。对不起，我情绪激动了。你就是无法衡量那些东西。
Elizabeth Bintliff told us Heifer does try to measure certain things about their programs. She said Heifer's worked with independent researchers who study Heifer projects.
伊丽莎白·宾特利夫告诉我们Heifer确实试图衡量他们项目中某些东西。她说Heifer与研究Heifer项目的独立研究人员合作。
The University of Western Michigan evaluates Heifer's projects and has found that there is a very positive return to families in terms of income, nutrition, and other indicators-- gender relations, children's welfare, education, and so on.
西密歇根大学评估了Heifer的项目，发现家庭在收入、营养和其他指标方面有非常积极的回报——性别关系、儿童福利、教育等等。
Do you know what any of the numbers are from that study?
你知道那项研究中的任何数字吗？
I can send those to you, yes.
我可以发给你，是的。
But after we talked to Elizabeth, we got an email from Heifer. It said, thanks for your interest in those Western Michigan evaluations but, quote, "as the sources cited are unpublished, we're not able to provide further information publicly at this time."
但在我们和伊丽莎白交谈后，我们收到了Heifer的一封电子邮件。上面写着，谢谢你对那些西密歇根评估的兴趣，但，“由于所引用的来源是未发表的，我们目前无法公开提供更多信息。”
So we asked Heifer for whatever they could show us about what their projects cost and what they achieve. They told us that, according to a progress report for the project we visited, families make about $950 a year off their cows. But they said that number, quote, "is not meant to be considered an analysis of the project. It is information collected at the project level by field staff." And they wouldn't show us the report.
所以我们要求Heifer提供任何他们能向我们展示的东西，关于他们的项目成本和成就。他们告诉我们，根据我们访问的项目进度报告，家庭每年从牛身上赚取约950美元。但他们说那个数字，“并不是作为项目的分析。这是由现场工作人员在项目层面收集的信息。”他们不让我们看报告。
We also asked how much it cost to provide a family with a cow and training. Heifer told us it varies from family to family, and they couldn't provide a number.
我们也问了为家庭提供一头牛和培训需要多少钱。Heifer告诉我们，每家都不一样，他们无法提供一个数字。
Giving cash with no strings attached clearly has limits. Even if it works in rural Kenya, it may not work so well in Asia or in urban areas. It won't magically fix all the other things that keep people poor. It won't end civil wars or fix corrupt governments or create new vaccines. But even if it just helps poor people climb up a couple rungs, that would be a huge accomplishment.
无条件发出现金显然有限度。即使它在肯尼亚农村有效，在亚洲或城市地区可能效果不佳。它不会神奇地解决让人们保持贫困的所有其他事情。它不会结束内战、修复腐败政府或创造新疫苗。但即使它只是帮助穷人爬上几层梯级，那也将是一个巨大的成就。
And here's something else-- until pretty recently, the charity world has been about doing stuff that helps without really thinking, well, how much does it help exactly, and how much does it cost? And there does seem to be this shift that's happening, a shift away from glossy brochures and smiling children and happy anecdotes, a shift toward data. Philanthropy is getting nerdier.
还有一件事——直到最近，慈善界一直都在做有助于他人的事情，却没有真正思考，嗯，它到底帮了多少，成本是多少？确实看起来正在发生这种转变，从光鲜的宣传册、微笑的儿童和快乐的轶事中转变，向数据转变。慈善事业变得更极客了。
Last year, the GiveDirectly guys gave a presentation at the corporate charity office of Google, a place where data counts for a lot. In the presentation, they didn't show any pictures of people. What they did show were charts and studies and lots of numbers, and the people at Google were impressed. In fact, they gave GiveDirectly $2.4 million and told Paul and Michael, you're thinking too small. Go figure out how to give money to lots more poor people.
去年，“直接给予”团队在谷歌的企业慈善办公室做了演讲，那是一个数据非常重要的地方。在演讲中，他们没展示任何人的照片。他们展示的是图表、研究和大量数字，谷歌的人印象深刻。事实上，他们给了“直接给予”240万美元，告诉保罗和迈克尔，你们想得太小了。去弄清楚如何给更多的穷人发钱吧。
Jacob Goldstein and David Kestenbaum for Planet Money, which is a co-production of our program and NPR News. Their blog and twice-weekly podcast about economics, but for the rest of us who don't necessarily give a damn about economics, is at npr.org/money.
这是雅各布·戈德斯坦和戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆为《货币星球》做的报道，该节目是我们节目和NPR新闻的联合制作。他们关于经济学的博客和每周两次的播客，适合我们这些对经济学未必感兴趣的人，网址是npr.org/money。
Coming up, a sheriff tries to keep lots of deputies on the street, tries to make their jobs more efficient, tries to bust big illegal drug operations, all by making peace with marijuana growers. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，一位警长试图让街道上有更多的巡警，试图让他们的工作更有效率，试图捣毁大型非法毒品行动，所有这些都是通过与大麻种植者达成和平协议来实现的。那将在一分钟后继续进行，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续。
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on the program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "I Was Just Trying to Help"-- stories of people, you know, doing exactly that.
这里是《这个美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，带给你们关于该主题的不同种类的故事。今天的节目，“我只是想帮忙”——关于人们做这件事的故事。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Nipped in the Bud.
我们到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，扼杀在萌芽状态。
So here's a problem that somebody's gotta step in and help with-- what are we going to do about marijuana, you know? Lots of states have made moves to legalize it in various ways in recent years. It has just made it more complicated. It's really kind of a mess.
所以这里有个需要有人介入并帮忙解决的问题——关于大麻我们该怎么办？你知道？近年来许多州已采取行动以各种方式将其合法化。这让事情变得更加复杂。这真的是一团糟。
Case in point, it's been over a decade since California allowed medical marijuana and they still have not figured out exactly how to handle it. Lots of people with no actual medical need are getting lots of marijuana. How much you're allowed to grow or buy or possess varies from county to county. State law says that you can possess up to 8 ounces of processed marijuana, but it also says that if your doctor decides you need more, it's OK to have more. At one point, in Mendocino County, in the northern part of the state, where most of the pot is grown, it was legal to have up to 2 pounds of the stuff. But if you went to Lake County just right next door with that amount of pot, you were breaking the law.
以这个为例，距离加州允许医用大麻已经过去了十多年，他们仍然没弄清楚到底该如何处理。许多根本没有实际医疗需求的人正在获得大量大麻。你被允许种植、购买或拥有多少大麻因县而异。州法律说你可以拥有最多8盎司处理过的大麻，但它也说如果你的医生决定你需要更多，拥有更多是可以的。曾经有一度，在州北部的门多西诺县，那里种植了大部分大麻，拥有最多2磅的大麻是合法的。但如果你带着那种数量的大麻去隔壁的莱克县，你就触犯了法律。
It's confusing even for cops. There are situations for cops without any clear path about what you're supposed to do. This next story is a story about one of those situations and a cop who was trying to do the right thing, trying to help his community as best he can figure out to, in Mendocino County. Mary Cuddehe tells what happened.
这对警察来说都很令人困惑。对于警察来说，有些情况根本没有关于你应该怎么做的清晰路径。下一个故事是关于这些情况之一，以及一位试图做正确的事、试图以他所能想到的最好方式帮助他的社区的警察，在门多西诺县。玛丽·库德赫讲述了发生的事。
When I sat down with Tom Allman, the elected sheriff of Mendocino County, I asked him what I thought was a pretty straightforward question about marijuana.
当我坐下来和门多西诺县民选警长汤姆·奥尔曼谈话时，我问了他一个我认为关于大麻的问题，相当直接。
Do you have any estimates of how many people are actually growing in Mendocino County?
你对门多西诺县到底有多少人在种植有任何估计吗？
That is the funniest question I have heard in a year. Do I have any estimate of the percentage or the number of people who are growing in Mendocino County? I know I have never thought of that question. I've never thought of the answer.
这是我一年中听到的最有趣的问题。我对门多西诺县种植的人员比例或人数有任何估计吗？我知道我从来没想过这个问题。我从来没想过答案。
When California legalized medical marijuana in 1996, growers started flocking to Mendocino looking to cash in. Mendocino's a couple of hours north of San Francisco, and picture it for a second-- it's huge, mostly rural, there's lots of dense forest. It's basically the perfect place to hide a pot garden. And now there's so much pot growing, it's not even worth guessing how much is there.
当加州在1996年将医用大麻合法化时，种植者开始涌向门多西诺寻找机会。门多西诺在旧金山以北几个小时的路程，请想象一下——它非常巨大，多为乡村，有茂密的森林。它基本上是隐藏大麻园的完美地点。现在那里种植了如此多的大麻，甚至不值得猜测有多少。
All kinds of people are growing, from old hippies tending a few plants in their backyard to-- and this was the big problem-- criminals running massive industrial size pot farms in the forest on both public and private land. Sheriff Allman knew these illegal growers were wreaking havoc in the forest. They'd lay miles of pipe to divert water from rivers where salmon run, spray pesticides, and then just leave their trash behind after harvest.
各种各样的人都在种植，从后院照料几株植物的老嬉皮士到——这就是大问题——在公共和私人土地的森林里经营大规模工业级大麻农场的罪犯。奥尔曼警长知道这些非法种植者正在森林里制造混乱。他们铺设数英里的管道从三文鱼洄游的河流中引水，喷洒杀虫剂，然后在收获后把垃圾留在那。
And they posed an even bigger threat-- they were armed. At a meeting with the County Board of Supervisors in 2010, residents gave Sheriff Allman an earful.
而且他们构成了更大的威胁——他们武装了。在2010年与县监事会的一次会议上，居民们向奥尔曼警长倾诉了不满。
I believe 11 citizens spoke that morning. And of the 11, 8 said something similar to, "In the National Forest this year, I was shot at." Or, "In National Forest this year, I was out grazing my cattle or I was out recreating and someone started shooting at me."
我相信那天早上有11位市民发言。在11位中，有8位说了类似的话：“今年在国家森林里，我被人开枪了。”或者，“今年在国家森林里，我出去放牛或出去休闲，有人开始对我开枪。”
And every time a citizen got up and said that, there were five members of the board-- and I was sitting there in uniform, just like this. And every time someone would say, yeah, I was up there, you know, driving around and I got shot at, there were five sets of eyes who all turned and looked at me like, Sheriff, what are you going to do about this?
每当有市民站起来说那样的话时，董事会有五名成员——而我正穿着制服坐在那，就像现在这样。每当有人说，是的，我在那，你知道，开车四处走动时被人开枪了，会有五双眼睛转过来看着我，就像，警长，你打算怎么做？
Sheriff Allman actually had an idea, an idea that would free up his staff to go after the bad guys. His idea was, to get those guys, first bring order to the world of small-time legal growers. He couldn't just ignore the small fry, because no matter how small they were, his office kept getting calls about them.
奥尔曼警长确实有个想法，一个可以让他的员工腾出手去追捕坏人的想法。他的想法是，要抓那些家伙，首先要给小规模合法种植者的世界带来秩序。他不能忽视小喽啰，因为不管他们多小，他的办公室一直收到关于他们的电话。
At the start of each growing season, Allman says the number one 911 call was about the smell of blooming pot gardens. It can be pretty bad-- it smells like skunk. And each time, the Sheriff's Department had to respond, even though county law said it was legal for residents to have up to 25 plants with a doctor's recommendation.
在每个种植季节开始时，奥尔曼说911接到最多的电话是关于开花的大麻园的味道。那气味相当难闻——闻起来像臭鼬。每次，警长部门都必须响应，即使县法律规定居民拥有最多25株植物（带有医生推荐）是合法的。
So people would call the cops, the Sheriff's Office would have to send someone out, check if the grower had a doctor's note, check that the note was legit, count the plants, fill out paperwork. Best case scenario, the deputy has spent an hour verifying that everything is perfectly fine. It was a waste of Allman's resources and he thought, there has to be a better way.
所以人们会打电话报警，警长办公室必须派人去，检查种植者是否有医生证明，检查证明是否合法，清点植物，填写文书工作。最好的情况是，副警长花了一个小时核实一切都完全没问题。这对奥尔曼的资源是种浪费，他想，一定有更好的方式。
So I came up with the idea of zip ties. You know what a zip tie is? A piece of plastic that has a serial number on it that is about 18 inches long. And we said, all right, here's what the plan is-- if you have a legitimate recommendation from a doctor and you bring that into the Sheriff's Office, we will give you zip ties, no cost.
所以我有了塑料扎带的想法。你知道什么是塑料扎带吗？一块有序列号的塑料，大约18英寸长。我们说，好了，计划就是这样——如果你有医生的合法推荐，你把它带到警长办公室，我们将免费给你扎带。
And what you're supposed to do is take these zip ties to your house and go to the base of the mature, flowering, female marijuana plant. And that way, when our law enforcement officers come to your house, we could actually look at that serial number and we could track it back to you and say, all right, you were growing these with legitimacy.
你应该做的是把这些扎带带回家，系在成熟、开花、雌性大麻植物的根部。那样，当我们的执法人员来到你家时，我们可以查看序列号，追溯到你，并说，好了，你是合法种植这些的。
Around the same time Allman was looking into zip ties, the County Board of Supervisors was also trying to find a fix. They proposed new rules saying that marijuana could only be grown a certain number of feet from schools and churches. It couldn't be visible from the road. You could already grow 25 plants, but the board knew people were growing much more, saying they were running co-ops, growing for other people.
就在奥尔曼研究扎带的同时，县监事会也在试图寻找解决办法。他们提出了新规则，说大麻种植距离学校和教堂必须有一定的距离。不能从路上可见。你本来已经可以种植25株植物，但董事会知道人们种植得更多，声称他们经营合作社，为其他人种植。
So after a big debate, the board decided that co-ops could have up to 99 plants, but there was a catch-- if you wanted to grow that much pot, you were required to sign up for Allman's zip tie program. And you'd have to pay-- $1,500 to register as a cooperative, $50 per zip tie. You'd be subject to inspections-- those cost $500. And all of that money went straight back to the Sheriff's Department. So if you've got 99 plants, you're paying around $8,000 a year for the cops to keep tabs on your weed.
所以在一场大争论后，董事会决定合作社最多可以有99株植物，但有一个附加条件——如果你想种那么多大麻，你必须报名参加奥尔曼的扎带项目。而且你必须付费——1500美元注册成为合作社，50美元一个扎带。你将接受检查——那些检查费500美元。所有这些钱都直接回到了警长部门。所以如果你有99株植物，你一年要支付大约8000美元让警察留意你的大麻。
All these new rules would be rolled into Mendocino County Ordinance 9.31, and that's what everyone called the 99 Plant Program, 9.31. As with any new rule to regulate pot in Mendocino, it attracted a ton of debate and critics. Even Sheriff Allman's own staff wasn't 100% behind him.
所有这些新规则都将被纳入门多西诺县条例9.31，这就是每个人所称的99株植物计划，9.31。就像门多西诺监管大麻的任何新规则一样，它引发了大量的辩论和批评。甚至奥尔曼警长自己的员工也没100%支持他。
What did your deputies think?
你的副警长们怎么想？
The sheriff is off his rocker. The sheriff is nuts. The sheriff is in on this. The sheriff supports marijuana. Well, no, I don't. You know, I'm sure that if you put a survey out to the deputy sheriffs, "Do you like the zip ties idea?" I surely wouldn't win a majority of the popularity contest.
警长疯了。警长脑子坏了。警长参与进去了。警长支持大麻。好吧，不，我没有。你知道，我相信如果你对副警长们做个调查，“你喜欢扎带的想法吗？”我肯定不会赢得人气大赛的多数。
Actually, there was a survey done-- an audit commissioned by the Board of Supervisors. And in it, some deputies said they supported the program, but others said it was, quote, "potentially criminal friendly, reduces morale, and is poised to bring more crime to the county and potential corruption to the department."
事实上，做过一项调查——监事会委托进行的一项审计。在审计中，一些副警长说他们支持该计划，但其他人说它是，“潜在的对罪犯友好，降低士气，并准备给县里带来更多犯罪和给部门带来潜在腐败。”
The board passed the new rule by a vote of three to two, and once 9.31 got up and running, it worked. The first year, 18 people signed up. By the second year, 94 people had stepped forward to register with the Sheriff's Office. It meant that those people were out in the open, paying fees and-- this was new-- inviting cops into their homes to count their pot.
董事会以三比二的投票通过了新规则，一旦9.31开始运行，它起作用了。第一年，18人报名。到第二年，94人站出来在警长办公室注册。这意味着这些人公开了，支付了费用，而且——这是新的——邀请警察进入他们的家来清点他们的大麻。
I was very excited to have clear regulations. I feel that overall it was a very healing time for the community.
我非常高兴有明确的法规。我觉得总的来说这对社区是一个非常治愈的时期。
Matt Cohen was one of the first farmers to sign up. He's known around Mendocino as the poster boy of 9.31. He's the guy who would talk to TV reporters and give them tours of his garden.
马特·科恩是第一批报名的农民之一。他在门多西诺被称为9.31的代言人。他是那个愿意与电视记者交谈并带他们参观他的花园的人。
Matt's operation was called Northstone Organics. His customers could get fresh vegetables, pasture-raised eggs, goat cheese, and 40 varieties of premium buds delivered straight to their door. Matt ran the operation on a 10-acre property where he and his wife also lived. They invested a lot of money and took the business seriously.
马特的业务叫北石有机（Northstone Organics）。他的客户可以直接送货上门新鲜蔬菜、牧场饲养的鸡蛋、山羊奶酪和40个品种的优质花蕾。马特在10英亩的土地上经营这个业务，他和妻子也住在那里。他们投入了大量金钱并认真对待业务。
We had 15-plus full time employees and a half dozen seasonal employees. There was a field out back that had the medicine growing that was in a very, very secure security system. We'd even had false alarms go off and the sheriff show up in less than 10 minutes.
我们有15个以上的全职员工和半打季节性员工。后院有一个领域种着药材，在一个非常、非常安全的保安系统中。我们甚至有假警报响起，警长在不到10分钟内赶到。
Northstone employees made between $19 and $28 an hour. They had health insurance and workman's comp. The county authorities saw Matt's co-op as a model for what regulated pot could be, because, remember, Matt Cohen wasn't just paying his employees, he was paying the county.
北石员工的时薪在19到28美元之间。他们有健康保险和工伤赔偿。县当局将马特的合作社视为监管大麻的典范，因为，记住，马特·科恩不仅在付给员工工资，他在付给县里钱。
At the time, Mendocino, like counties and states all across the country, was facing huge budget cuts. Allman had already been told that he needed to lay off five deputies. But 9.31 brought in almost a million dollars in the first two years, enough to keep those jobs.
当时，门多西诺，像全国各地的县和州一样，正面临巨大的预算削减。奥尔曼已经被告知他需要裁掉五名副警长。但9.31在前两年带来了近一百万美元，足以保住那些工作。
Allman felt like he had the resources to do what he wanted to do all along-- go after the big guys.
奥尔曼觉得他有资源去做他一直想做的事——去追捕那些大人物。
We continue our coverage tonight on Operation Full Court Press in the Mendocino National Forest.
今晚我们继续报道门多西诺国家森林的“全力压制”行动。
[HELICOPTER FLYING]
[直升机飞行声]
Allman orchestrated a huge bust in the summer of 2011. He called it Operation Full Court Press. It targeted illegal marijuana farms in the Mendocino National Forest. It was massive. Allman's forces were there, along with hundreds of agents from five other counties, the state, as well as the DEA and FBI.
奥尔曼在2011年夏天策划了一次大规模搜捕行动。他称之为“全力压制”行动。它针对的是门多西诺国家森林里的非法大麻农场。规模巨大。奥尔曼的部队在那，还有来自其他五个县、州、以及缉毒署（DEA）和联邦调查局（FBI）的数百名特工。
Over the past two weeks, Operation Full Court Press has seized over 460,000 marijuana plants, raided 56 grow sites, and made a total of 102 arrests.
在过去两周里，“全力压制”行动已经查封了超过46万株大麻，突袭了56个种植点，并进行了总共102次逮捕。
Pesticides and dozens of weapons were seized. The raid uncovered miles of irrigation piping, man-made dams, and 46,000 pounds of trash. Even the White House's drug czar commended the raid. Allman was succeeding on two fronts-- he was cracking down on the big, destructive growers and, with 9.31, he could keep an eye on some small time farmers.
查获了杀虫剂和几十件武器。突袭揭露了数英里的灌溉管道、人造水坝和4.6万磅垃圾。甚至白宫的禁毒主管都称赞了这次突袭。奥尔曼在两个战线上都取得了成功——他正在严厉打击那些大而具有破坏性的种植者，通过9.31，他可以留意一些小规模农民。
But the problem, of course, is that even though the state of California has legalized pot in all sorts of ways, the federal government says it's illegal, no matter what. Every year, the DEA raids small farms in Mendocino and other counties that under California law are perfectly legal. Medical marijuana dispensaries across the state have been shut down by the feds.
但问题当然是，尽管加州已通过各种方式将大麻合法化，联邦政府却说它违法，无论如何。每年，DEA都会突袭门多西诺和其他县的小农场，根据加州法律这些农场是完全合法的。全州的医用大麻药房都被联邦政府关闭了。
Allman knew that his program was a violation of federal law, but he's the county sheriff, so he's supposed to enforce state law. So really, in the scheme of things, Allman thought his program was safe because, again, his zip ties were just a way to streamline things, save his deputies some time, and get some money back for all the effort he was putting into marijuana. Plus, he'd been upfront with the federal government.
奥尔曼知道他的计划违反了联邦法律，但他是个县警长，所以他本应执行州法律。所以真的，从大局来看，奥尔曼认为他的计划是安全的，因为，再次说明，他的扎带只是为了精简流程、节省他副警长的时间并为他投入到大麻上的所有努力获得一些回报。另外，他也对联邦政府开诚布公。
On August 24, 2011, I spent an hour and a half briefing the US Attorney for Northern California, the FBI supervisor of Northern California, four other sheriffs, and four district attorneys about 9.31. I told them all the aspects of it. This is what we're doing, this is how we're doing it, these are the problems we expect, this is how we're going to take care of the problems. And on that date, I didn't have anybody, especially from the federal government, stand up and say, you can't do that. They all said the same thing-- oh, this is interesting.
2011年8月24日，我花了一个半小时向北加州联邦检察官、北加州FBI主管、其他四位警长和四位地区检察官简要介绍了9.31。我告诉了他们所有的方面。这是我们正在做的，这是我们这样做的方式，这是我们预期的困难，这是我们将如何解决这些困难。在那一天，没有人，特别是联邦政府的人，站出来说，你不能那样做。他们都说了同样的话——哦，这很有意思。
The Department of Justice wouldn't agree to an interview for this story, but a spokesman for Melinda Haag, the US Attorney for the Northern District, says she didn't take the news quietly, that she stood up during that meeting and said, what he's describing is not consistent with federal law.
司法部不同意为这个故事接受采访，但北区联邦检察官梅琳达·哈格的发言人说，她并没有安静地接受这个消息，她在会议期间站起来说，他所描述的与联邦法律不一致。
I talked to a couple of other people who were there and their accounts differed slightly. They said that Melinda Haag simply reiterated the federal position, saying marijuana is a violation of federal law. And the Mendocino County district attorney told me she added, "But I'm not passing judgement at this time on the Mendocino model."
我和其他几个在场的人谈过，他们的说法略有不同。他们说梅琳达·哈格只是重申了联邦的立场，说大麻违反了联邦法律。门多西诺县地区检察官告诉我，她补充说，“但我目前不对门多西诺模式进行评判。”
Then on October 13, 2011, a little over two months after that meeting with federal officials, Allman got a call.
然后2011年10月13日，在与联邦官员的那次会议两个多月后，奥尔曼接到了一个电话。
Just to let you know, Sheriff, we're raiding Matt Cohen's property. And certainly, Matt Cohen can tell you his side of the story of what happened.
只是通知你，警长，我们正在突袭马特·科恩的房产。当然，马特·科恩可以告诉你他那一侧发生的事情的故事。
Sure. Not my most fun memory. Well, my wife and I were sleeping in our home, in our bed, and I heard the dog start barking. And I jumped out of bed and looked out the window, and there was what looked to be federal vehicles driving very fast into our driveway. I looked to my wife and I said, "We're being raided by the federal government." Because obviously, we never expected to be raided by the Sheriff's Department.
好的。不是我最有趣的记忆。嗯，我和妻子当时在家里睡觉，在床上，我听到狗开始叫。我跳下床看了看窗外，那里似乎有联邦车辆正飞快地驶进我们的车道。我看着妻子说，“我们被联邦政府突袭了。”因为显然，我们从没指望被警长部门突袭。
And they showed up at the front door with machine guns drawn. There was, I think, eight of them. I said, "Don't shoot the dogs, they're friendly, and I'm cooperating." And I told them there was an alarm that would call the Sheriff's Department if they kicked down the door.
他们拿着机关枪冲到了前门。我想有八个人。我说，“别开枪打狗，它们很友好，我正在配合。”我告诉他们，如果他们踢开门，警报会打给警长部门。
They did kick down the door, tripping the alarm, but the DEA told the sheriff not to come. The agents handcuffed Matt and his wife and put them on the front porch. They sat there for eight hours while the agents took chainsaws to their 99 plants and tore through their house. His computers and cell phones were seized, along with any paperwork related to Allman's zip tie program.
他们确实踢开了门，触发了警报，但DEA告诉警长不要过来。特工给马特和他妻子戴上手铐并把他们放在前门廊。他们在那里坐了八个小时，特工拿着电锯锯掉了他们的99株植物并搜查了他们的房子。他的电脑和手机被查封，连同任何与奥尔曼扎带计划有关的文件。
I mean, I got the impression that they thought the Sheriff's Department was just as much of a crooks as they thought we were. [LAUGHS]
我的意思是，我得到了一个印象，他们认为警长部门和他们认为的一样是一帮骗子。[笑]
Did somebody say that?
有人这么说吗？
Yeah. Yeah, they said it was a sham and that-- I could be paraphrasing, but it seemed like they thought that those guys should be in jail.
是的。是的，他们说这是一个骗局，而且——我可能是在转述，但他们似乎认为那些家伙应该进监狱。
So when they arrived and you said, look, this is a program regulated by the county, they laughed it off?
所以当他们到达时，你说，看，这是受县里监管的一个项目，他们嘲笑它？
Yeah. I actually thought that they were at the wrong house. I said, do you know who we are? We're Northstone Organics. I mean, you can see on TV who we are, that we're legitimate, that we're licensed, that we're doing everything right. There's 99 plants here, why are you guys here? And they didn't respond.
是的。我实际上以为他们走错了房子。我说，你知道我们是谁吗？我们是北石有机。我的意思是，你可以在电视上看到我们是谁，我们是合法的，我们是有执照的，我们做的一切都是对的。这里有99株植物，你们为什么在这？他们没回应。
Matt wasn't charged, but there are a lot of theories in Mendocino, or at least rumors, about why he was raided. Theory number one, almost everyone I talked to said that shutting down the poster boy of 9.31 was payback. The county program flew in the face of federal law, was an embarrassment to the US Justice Department, and so the DEA pulled the plug in the most public way possible. Or maybe Allman's deputies, who didn't like the zip ties, had complained to the feds.
马特没被起诉，但在门多西诺有很多理论，或者至少是谣言，关于他为什么被突袭。理论一，我谈过的几乎每个人都说关闭9.31的代言人是一种报复。县计划无视联邦法律，是美国司法部的尴尬，所以DEA以尽可能公开的方式拔掉了插头。或者，也许不喜欢扎带的奥尔曼的副警长向联邦举报了。
The most interesting theory I heard was from John McCowen, another member of the Board of Supervisors. He had worked closely with the sheriff to develop 9.31 and he thinks that when the Feds came to Mendocino to help with Operation Full Court Press, that big bust in the forest, they didn't like what they were seeing.
我听到的最有趣的理论来自约翰·麦考恩，监事会的另一名成员。他曾与警长密切合作制定9.31，他认为当联邦人员来到门多西诺协助“全力压制”行动（森林里那次大搜捕）时，他们不喜欢他们所看到的。
They felt like they'd stepped into the Wild West. People were openly growing marijuana with a rubber stamp from the sheriff. In Matt Cohen's online newsletter, for instance, he advertised his product this way-- "Pedigree medical cannabis plants growing this week on our Mendocino County Sheriff's Department permitted farm." You can imagine how that sort of thing would rankle the DEA.
他们觉得他们像是走进了狂野西部。人们在警长的橡皮图章下公开种植大麻。例如，在马特·科恩的在线通讯中，他是这样宣传他的产品的——“纯种医用大麻植物，本周种植在我们门多西诺县警长部门许可的农场。”你可以想象那种事情会如何激怒DEA。
County Supervisor John McCowen says he thinks federal authorities wanted to make sure no other county adopted the Mendocino model, which was getting a lot of attention.
县监事约翰·麦考恩说他认为联邦当局想确保没有其他县采用门多西诺模式，这引起了很多关注。
I do have it on good authority that the federal attorney and others were actually getting calls saying, "We understand what Mendocino County is doing is working very well. How do we do that?"
我有可靠消息称，联邦检察官和其他人实际上接到了电话说，“我们理解门多西诺县所做的非常有效。我们怎么做那个？”
Again, the Department of Justice wouldn't speak with us, but they did confirm that the Northern District got at least one call along these lines and that they replied that the Mendocino program was a violation of federal law. Sheriff Allman told me he had also spoken to half a dozen sheriffs from other counties, both inside and outside California, who all wanted to know how the program worked.
再次，司法部不会与我们交谈，但他们确实确认北区接到了至少一个这样的电话，他们回复说门多西诺计划违反了联邦法律。奥尔曼警长告诉我他也和来自其他县的半打警长谈过，加州内外都有，他们都想知道这个计划是如何运作的。
Shortly after the raid on Matt's co-op, the County Board of Supervisors decided the pressure from the federal government was too much. They amended Ordinance 9.31, shut the program down. You couldn't grow 99 plants anymore. You could still buy zip ties, you could still grow 25 plants if you had a letter from the doctor, but the inspections, the fees, the oversight-- everything that had made the small farmers feel protected and Allman feel like he was making some progress-- all of that was gone.
马特的合作社被突袭后不久，县监事会决定来自联邦政府的压力太大了。他们修改了条例9.31，关闭了该计划。你不能再种99株植物了。你仍然可以买扎带，如果你有医生信你仍然可以种25株植物，但检查、费用、监督——所有那些让小农民感到受保护、让奥尔曼感到他取得了一些进展的一切——所有这些都没了。
Even so, the Department of Justice subpoenaed the county, demanding they hand over all records of the 9.31 program, including the names of everyone who participated. It really freaked people out. What exactly was the federal government planning to do with that information? Eventually, last spring, the two sides struck a deal. The county handed over some records, but withheld the names of the farmers.
即便如此，司法部向该县发出了传票，要求他们交出所有9.31计划的记录，包括参与者的名字。这真让人们吓坏了。联邦政府到底打算用那些信息做什么？最终，去年春天，双方达成了一项协议。县里交出了一些记录，但保留了农民的名字。
Mendocino's experiment is over, and for Allman, it means that he's right back where he started.
门多西诺的实验结束了，对奥尔曼来说，这意味着他回到了原点。
Think of it. Two years ago, people were paying cops $500 a month to come to their house, count the number of marijuana plants, make sure they weren't stealing water, make sure they weren't using dangerous environmental practices and they weren't spilling diesel. I mean, what better solution is there than to have this open communication? But we're not going to have that now.
想想吧。两年前，人们付给警察每月500美元来他们家，清点大麻植物的数量，确保他们没偷水，确保他们没使用危险的环境做法，确保他们没泄漏柴油。我的意思是，还有什么比拥有这种公开交流更好的解决办法吗？但我们现在不会有那个了。
In Mendocino, you can still walking into Sheriff Allman's office and buy zip ties. When I talked to him earlier this year, he figured no one would bother, not after the raid and the federal subpoena. He hadn't even ordered a resupply. But surprisingly, 69 people have bought zip ties so far this year. He just sold some the other day. That's 69 people who know their pot won't get confiscated by the sheriff. They can't be so sure about the DEA.
在门多西诺，你仍然可以走进奥尔曼警长的办公室买扎带。当我在今年早些时候和他谈话时，他以为没人会打扰，突袭和联邦传票之后。他甚至没订购补给。但令人惊讶的是，今年已经有69人买了扎带。他前几天刚卖了一些。那69个人知道他们的大麻不会被警长没收。他们对DEA可不能那么确定。
Mary Cuddehe.
玛丽·库德赫。
[MUSIC - "MARIJUANA, THE DEVIL FLOWER" BY JOHNNY PRICE]
[音乐 - 约翰尼·普赖斯的《大麻，恶魔之花》]
Our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Dana Chivvis. Seth Lind is our operations director, Emily Condon's our production manager, Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant, Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Music help from Damien Graef, from Rob Geddis.
我们的节目今天由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·柯尼格、美树·米克、丽莎·波拉克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克共同制作。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。达娜·奇维斯提供了制作帮助。赛斯·林德是我们的运营总监，艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理，伊莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理，阿德里安娜·马蒂沃维茨经营我们的网站。米歇尔·哈里斯和朱莉·比尔提供了研究帮助。达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。本节目由公共广播国际公司发行。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Torey Malatia. And he called everybody on staff to find out how they all spent this year's annual bonus. He just gave me a report--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚。他给全体员工打电话，想了解他们每个人是如何花掉今年的年度奖金的。他刚给了我一份报告——
--so some of them are drunkards, so they used it to buy alcohol. Others just spent the whole amount on food and became fat.
——所以有些人是酒鬼，所以他们用了它去买酒精。其他人只是把整笔钱花在食物上，吃成了胖子。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《这个美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "MARIJUANA, THE DEVIL FLOWER" BY JOHNNY PRICE]
[音乐 - 约翰尼·普赖斯的《大麻，恶魔之花》]
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际公司。